[Music]
foreign there you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with papakura
political editor of the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor of the sun
great to see both of you
before we hear from them the front pages
let's kick off shall we with
the telegraph on the day supermarkets
are in the firing line over fuel prices
the telegraph has the headline motorists
used as fuel Cash Cow by Grocers the eye
has carried out a poll which reveals
that 67 of people also want a cap on
Supermarket prices generally to help
them cope with the soaring cost of
living news that last month was
officially the hottest June on record is
the top story for the Metro the headline
flaming June proposed new curbs on
immigration numbers lead the express
which says the proposals have been
blocked by the treasury a move which has
split the conservative party
papakura has tonight's lead story in the
guardian about Labor plans to improve
Nursery education for the underfores the
financial times says Bank Chiefs have
been called in by the financial
regulator to explain why saving rates
are lagging so far behind the rising
cost of mortgages well the Daily Mail
says banks are also facing investigation
over closing the accounts of people who
Express controversial views and the
Daily Star returns to its favorite
source of stories scientific buffins who
say that people's brains are shrinking
because of eating a bad diet while
Harry's paper the sun focuses on the
marital ups and downs of emmerdale's Amy
Nuttall and her act her husband Andrew
buckin how'd you pronounce his name
buccane
no everyone's looking at me
anyway reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages
Optimus newspapers while you watch us so
let's uh get the thoughts of Pippa and
Harry and that theme really about
Supermarket prices fuel prices
um and indeed the idea of savings rates
lagging kicking off though Pippa with
the eye this idea of a supermarket price
cab which I thought had been ruled out
by the government it seems tempting to
Consumers but presumably it would have
knock-on impact for Farmers for example
wouldn't it
yeah I mean this is a policy which
actually hasn't been used since the
1970s
um but it was briefly considered last
month when food inflation looked like it
was stubbornly staying High
um it's 18.4 uh at the moment but
earlier this year it reached a 45-year
high of 19.1 which is you know a massive
figure and one which we all feel when we
go to the supermarkets and fill up our
uh fill up our trolleys um and you know
even the most basic Goods milk eggs
bread things like that I've soared have
soared in in price
um and the story on the eye is is
actually based on a poll which finds
that 60 67 sorry of the public back
price controls
um you know caps on some of those Basics
Goods I mentioned like eggs and and
bread and so on
um and uh just 13 oppose the idea but as
you rightly say even though it was
briefly considered last month within
Whitehall number 10 in the treasury
ultimately rejected the idea obviously
they wouldn't feel that they wanted to
interfere in the markets and as you
rightly say there could be knock-on
effects
um but they have worn supermarkets both
the treasury number 10 and the bank of
England against using inflation to
rebuild profit margins which have been
hammered for a variety of reasons
including energy cost soaring post
Ukraine and of course the pandemics so
um I think the pressure that households
are feeling means that this this subject
isn't going to go away the inflation
remains High crucially Core inflation
and food price inflation and as long as
the public continues to feel the pain
the government is going to have it at
the top of this inbox and how it's going
to drive down inflation yes and I
thought that supermarkets or the
bodies suggest that actually
supermarkets run very low profit margins
you know it's a quantity business that's
where they get any profit from
um so is it a fair accusation against
them do you think because we're going to
come on to the fuel pump priced in a
moment in city am but just in terms of
grocery
um is it something the government's very
concerned about Harry
yeah I think it is and you can see the
the difference in certain prices of
certain foods some sort of some brands
are much more expensive than others for
everyone is essentially the same product
so there is a suspicion that perhaps
actually there is a bit of gram I think
they call it greed flation where under
the cover of soaring prices
um some products are kept artificially
High to go up at the same rate as other
products that are you know perhaps
oil-based products that are suffering
from the war in Ukraine
um where actually you know the
production cost of those products aren't
as expensive as some things that are
going up but they put the prices up
anyway now the supermarkets say heaven
forbid how dare you suggest we do such a
thing but um there is a lingering
suspicion just on that poll though I
think that 67 is quite um quite a
thumping uh quite something number often
in that case as though you've got to
look at how the question was asked I
don't suspect that that the question was
would you like to see price caps in
supermarkets even though that would
automatically lead to less choice and
automatically lead to property shortages
because everywhere price caps are tried
that is the inevitable result yes indeed
and I know Farmers for example don't
think they get a fair price for milk for
example so there is a knock-on impact
and I suppose the supermarkets would say
that every price goes up because
transport costs go up and you know
that's the difficulty
um so what about the findings that we've
had reported in cityam you know and by
ourselves today that actually there was
a bit of inflation in the price of
petrol and Diesel over the last year
which has cost you know nearly
um uh you know 6p per liter three pounds
per time we visit a petrol station
effectively pepper
yeah I mean this is the results of a
year-long uh inquiry by the competition
and markets Authority which have looked
at the competition Watchdog which has
looked at what's going on on petrol4
courts where obviously we've seen prices
going up quite substantially and they're
suggesting that um petrol uh would have
maybe been six pence a liter or cheaper
had wholesalers passed on and retailers
passed on uh the wholesale savings and I
think it's even more I can't remember
the exact figure I heard earlier it was
about 13p or something like that for um
for diesel but anyway it's a it was a
larger increase and the super super
market fuel margins these are between
2019 and 2022 and City am says 900
million pounds almost a billion was
siphon debt of customers profits in
total so there's various things are
going to happen
um the government said it's going to
legislate to guarantee more transparency
in the market in a bit down to price to
drive down prices over the time
um and the CMA is calling for a plan to
help drivers get fairer prices including
new fuel monitoring body to hold the
industry to account City am says that
that could also be backed up with
legislation as well to make fewer
retailers provide up-to-date up-to-date
pricing day all right update data on
pricing I mean this all comes back to
the same thing is that consumers are
really feeling the pinch on top of all
the other cost of living pressures
they're feeling it at the supermarkets
they're feeling it at the petrol for
courts and the authorities the
governments and the various arms length
bodies are going to have to act to try
and ease some of that pressure and on a
slightly different but kind of connected
story and the financial times reporting
that the financial Watchdog is summoning
bank chief Executives to address
concerns that saving rates are lagging
behind the surging cost of mortgages
um to whatever thus I think probably
um but again this has also been a
concern of of people isn't it that you
know the banks gain while punishing
others effectively
yeah it just feels wherever we are
across the land there's an overstuffed
regulator that you know has all these
hundreds of peoples working for it but
doesn't it seem to be sort of acting
after the horse is bolted and only
really seem to to be acting now after
sort of public pressure whether that's
off what and off Gem and the water
regulator dare I say of common while on
television but I won't but it just seems
you know the FCA now playing catch up on
savings and the sun has been calling for
a pump watch there's this regulator for
Supermarket prices for months and months
and months years in fact as long as I
can remember we've been saying look
supermarkets are ripping people off and
the big four have finally been named and
shamed but it's taken years to get to
this point and that's absurd and
especially you know it shouldn't have
taken that massive soaring of petrol
prices last uh last year in the wake of
the invasion of Ukraine
um to get to this point you know
government being asleep at the world for
this for for more than a decade now and
you he's just saying you know what are
all these people doing what you know
what are what are these Regulators
stuffed over staff the people when you
know they seem to be failing on on every
account I'm going to stay with you if
it's all right um because it's uh inside
the Sun um Harry uh which is um rishi's
Summit on tackling the ecotoffs tell us
more
yeah so Wednesday
um Wednesday I think morning he's going
to be meeting with the cops he's going
to be bringing in sporting bodies the
big organizers bought the football uh
the football managing bodies
um to basically say look you've got to
sort this out we've got a new football
season starting we've got two weeks of
Wimbledon we've got three more test
matches we've got the British Grand Prix
um sort this out you know Johnny
birthday Managed IT the Prime Minister
makes the point in an op-ed in the sun
tomorrow you know you've got the laws
you've got the powers we've given you
those Powers now start using them so a
bit of a sort of banging their heads
together I think coming because the
point the prime ministers make is that
you know these protests are happening in
every other country around the world but
it's only us that seems to be putting up
with it so so frequently uh and allowing
a couple of you know sort of Eco swampy
trustiferian types to ruin days out for
everyone else so um we I believe it when
they see it when I see it actually
happen but um again once again it does
feel like the horse is somewhat bolted
the stable uh and the door is flapping
open and uh and the prime minister's
already now really is uh beginning to
try to shut it yes and and you know
controversy uh rages about the efficacy
of these protests Pippa but also about
the police Powers as well which were
themselves controversial
yes and of course
um the police have uh more ramped up
Powers uh I think was last year that
they came in in order to be able to
crack down on some of these these
protests um but uh civil rights groups
felt that they went too far uh and that
actually there was existing legislation
that they could have used but
increasingly it seems that uh people are
feel that this specific group targeting
not just sports events but of course
we've seen them uh you know do slow go
slows is that what it's called
um you know marching down streets and
and sort of blocking traffic and so on
as well the ending station Rebellion
um uh I have really sort of got the
Public's backs up and
um so much so that I think one of the
original Founders
um of just stop oil and funders indeed
uh said a couple of weeks ago that
actually uh it was it was about time
that they that they we thought their
tactics because if they ended up just uh
antagonizing the public rather than when
them over to their arguments then
actually their points you know the point
of their protest was was questionable
and surely uh the one thing that they
they want to be doing is to win over the
public so that it exerts pressure on
politicians and if they're feeling to do
that then I think maybe some of these
tactics need to be Revisited and
um you know the fascinating thing is
we're looking at all these newspapers
that talk about this you know fuel uh
rip-off I think the Daily Mirror is
going on that the supermarket Scandal
about just stop oil protests at a time
when we've had June as as the confirmed
hottest June we've had since records
began and this sort of weirdness of
trying to get cheap fossil fuels at a
time when sea temperatures are raging
Harry does you know is there sort of as
as the eye gone off the boil was this
Boris Johnson's Baby and not Rishi sunax
is that is that what's happening in
government
26 here in the UK and you know some of
the environmental things that we saw
from the conservative government
sure but I mean we're living in a cost
of living crisis and you can ask us you
can ask any voter or any sun reader and
all the polls show that people
consistently put
um the cost of living crisis way ahead
in fact
um uh the poll we had last week you got
a poll of uh of the British electorate
where they had tackling the cost of
living crisis and reducing people's
prices at the tills at the pumps was
that was a number one issue uh facing
voters and dealing with Net Zero was
down at number eight so I don't think
anyone's taking them off the ball but
we're living in reality if the fact is
people are struggling now and you know
when you start lecturing about what they
you know getting carbon neutral in in 30
years time they look like you've come
from another planet so I think it's a
reflection on the fact that people
living there day-to-day lives are very
hard and it's almost impossible to
escape from that fact and you seem very
out of touch and I think the government
think they're onto something here with
the Justice oil thing with the with with
the pump watch fuel prices thing and
actually most people do not agree with
just up oil most people want to see the
book thrown at them they want to see
them locked up and one of the biggest
problems that labor has is they are seen
to be on the side of these people
because you know they are the ones that
have consistently voted against all this
legislation and are taking money off of
just up the old donors so you wonder
where there's a big old political fight
and you know labor looked like they're
on the way to number 10 but um I think
on this issue I think they're quite weak
yes and one wonders how long therefore
the cost of living and inflationary
pressures crisis continues and whether
it does have an impact on policy
proposals like you know ban on petrol
cars for example Pippa
foreign
Street said this morning that there was
not going to be any reversal or
withdrawal from that from that pledge
and I think the problem that governments
face or political parties of all colors
face is that while the very acute in the
moment cost of living crisis obviously
needs to be dealt with and people need
to be supported through it and we all
know the factors that have led us to
this position successive governments
haven't done enough when it comes to
preparing us for for a carbon neutral
future and you know long-term planning
Boris Johnson got this actually but
long-term planning is absolutely key
else we're going to end up in the same
position in five years 10 years 15 years
time and energy prices will increase as
our own supplies dwindle and fewer new
licenses get granted we won't be more
dependent on foreign states that produce
oil like you know parts of the Middle
East and so on and Russia if relations
ever ever get back to sort of some sort
of normalized position and actually in
terms of long-term energy security it's
not just about security aspect it's also
about driving done prices and control
ourselves so investment by successive
governments over a long period of time
up until this point would have eased
some of those pressures we'd have our
own renewable or generative energy here
in the UK and wouldn't have to be so
reliant on others so there is an
argument that while of course the cost
of living crisis in the Here and Now
needs to be addressed we also need to
take the long-term Approach at the same
time and make sure that's provision
there in future for being more
self-reliant when it comes to energy
okay fascinating both of you thank you
very much indeed pepper Harry speak to
you in just a moment next though are
banks carrying out chilling account
closures The Daily Mail says they face
an investigation that animal after this
break
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again
political editor of the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor of the sun
welcome back to both of you and people
are going to get your story in the
guardian if that's okay
um and there has been a great deal of
concern about firstly the cost of
nurseries and therefore how ratios of
care are changing and so what's the plan
that you've heard about from labor that
you've reported on here
well labor has decided that not to three
age group is absolutely critical I say
labor has decided this has long been
accepted by Leading experts in the in
the sector and of course the sector
itself that focusing on not to threes
absolutely critical if you're going to
try and create a Level Playing Field
when children start primary school and I
interviewed Bridget Phillips in the
shadow education secretary who said even
when she went to visit primary and
secretary school's head teachers would
say too if you if you if Libra win the
next election and end up in government
you end up running the DFE if you have
any money please focus it and not to
threes because that is the single best
way of trying to sort of create
opportunity and and eradicate inequality
and it's long proven people like Andrew
LED some of the Tory side as well as
obviously historically Tessa jowl who's
behind setting up labor sure start
centers have always agreed that this is
this is a priority so labor is basically
saying that this is going to be priority
and in terms of doing this and the story
that we've got on the front page of the
Guardian uh tomorrow is that they're
going to consider they're going to look
at putting in uh graduate educated so
um degree level teachers in nurseries of
course lots of stuff in the nurseries
cut in nurseries particularly private
ones and voluntary sexual ones are
currently
um uh not degree level educated they're
Nursery nurses and so on so it's about
raising quality across the board in the
nurseries that exist they're also going
to look at opening up more Nursery
places and Primary School settings
there's about I think it's about 1600
1700 primary schools across England and
only so it's 1300 primary schools across
England don't have earlier settings on
sites and another 400 do currently have
state maintained nurseries and labor
going to look at expanding that so
formally linking early years and child
care in with the education system to
sort of like create a situation where
that remains a focus regardless who ends
up being in government in the future yes
and certainly reception teachers have
often complained that children they get
you know often can't hold a pen or
sometimes cut and hold a pen or even
can't even go to the toilet on their own
sometimes as well so it is a big area
let's move on to the Metro shall we and
uh the story that um she who judged rule
breaking broke the rules
um uh tell us about that Harry
yeah well sort of
um I mean this is the sort of
long-running But ultimately
um slightly damp squibby investigation
by the cabinet office that um Sue gray
managed a slightly Water Hole by having
absolutely nothing to do with it
um so this was the the cabin obviously
the skin distressor was a civil
service-led investigation into the
former sort of Whitehall enforcer who
was actually not right at the center of
things right when she left but still
pretty closely involved at the very top
basically said look she she you know
evidence suggests that she contacted
kirst armor and oh sorry I contacted her
in October of last year she continued to
work for the civil service for four
months and therefore the rules were
broken because you didn't declare that
contact but they're sort of it's been
sort of lawyered to death the sort of
statement and so they inserted premium
fascia which basically means look we've
had a look at about it we can't prove it
either way you know this hasn't been
tested in any court or won't ever be but
it looks awesome will actually break the
rules and label quite right rightly
frankly have gone yeah booze Booyah to
that uh let's move on she starts in
September six month cooling period but
you know there is a lot of anger not
just on the ministerial side on official
side as well lots of civil servants
think that sugay's behavior did bring
the
um the notion of civil service
impartiality into dispute uh whether she
was you know whether she was be doing
anything wrong or briefing stamina
behind the backs or any any of that the
appearance of neutrality is as important
as the neutrality itself so lots of sore
sort of Saw sore wounds there the
amusing thing I think though is that the
way the polls are going if Sue gray
though carries on working for labor
Beyond past the general election when
the point she's been hired for she can
be back uh probably in Whitehall where
she left off with lots of people who are
quite grumpy with us still the Tories
might be gone but there'll be a lot of
senior civil servants who should have to
work with again who um frankly are
spitting tax okay um less than a minute
left on the last three daily mail uh
Pippa at the Nigel farage Bank Route
with further implications the paper says
yeah well there's a suggestion that I
mean Nigel farage obviously uh uh was
complaining the other day about his bank
account being shut down without warning
since then we've had a series of
campaign groups individuals saying that
similar had happened to them and it's
become a bit of a political storm
because it's not so you know I think the
loss of your viewers as well or some of
your viewers may have been in a in a
position
um a similar position and for faraj is
saying is that uh his account's been
closed because they don't like his views
on controversial topics the treasury uh
Andrew Griffiths the city Minister has
suggested that um it is good to look
into the allegations that uh overzealous
lenders are blocking clients without
good reason
um very story and peace have complained
Anthony Bryan who I think ran the
British Bankers Association I hope I've
got that that right
um I'm rushing you apologies we're
running out of time there I'm gonna have
to call a halt if you don't mind